what a beautiful night on this wednesday
night and on the mound tonight for your
detroit tigers it's terrick scooble been
fantastic in his last two starts jorge
ohtani the one-two swung on it missed
that's a good start for tarik school
against shoi ohtani really nice slider
here at the top of the strike zone and
shohei otani not able to get to this
pitch well located so now justin upton
best pitch in baseball still a
well-located fastball there's one that
missed with location and jay up sends it
out of here two nothing halos was a four
seen fastball matt 95 mile an hour
fastball and jay up goes uptown funk
17th home run now just two rbis away
from a thousand with a two run home run
now the one two
swung on and missed a couple of
strikeouts but a couple of runs allowed
for terrex scuba in the first once the
calendar turned into july
shohei ohtani's pitching game has gone
to a new level five starts over that
time
and since july 1st he is 4-0 7-1 overall
2-2 home to grossman struck him out that
was the fastball he threw and that was
the reaction that baseball had some late
movement to it now listen to the hand
for miguel cabrera
i love it another one too
ripped through the hole on the left side
a base hit from miguel cabrera
now 48 hits shy of 3 000 in his career
mickey's staying through that baseball
yeah a little bit out front but because
he stays through it that allows him to
barrel it up enough to give himself a
knock in the second derrick school
against joe adel to start
swung on and missed
down goes adele guys away when he gets
you to two strikes it's going to be huge
for him
down goes marsh three straight
strikeouts
for terrex scuba what's behind marsh
there and kind of freezes him you can
see him kind of bailing out of there
tommy stands in for the second time
today pokes one to right center field
grossman is there and he retires ohtani
on one pitch right here's david pleasure
the 2-2 home to fletcher on the ground
and past candelario into the corner
fletch on his way around first into
second
a two out double in the angels half of
the third
just like that fletches don't ever
mention the fact i haven't had an extra
base hit in a while because here it is
right down the line for
grossman on with two outs and jonathan
scope will be the next batter
and pops up here in the third that keeps
cabrera on the on deck circle another
good inning for rotani just seven
pitches justin upton leads off
swung on and missed school wins that
match nasty change up here about 10 mile
per hour speed difference but and you
see the face there oh yeah because
that's a really good pitch when you've
sped a hitter up in the batter's box on
the other hand google facing joe waddell
for the second time so here's the 2-1
to short for harold castro
second one two three inning for tarik
skubal miguel cabrera eyeing number 500
yet again
to third base
mayfield has been busy so far tonight
and cabrera in one pitch leads off the
fourth with an out carol castro now he's
singled in the second
wow he got him
broke out a nasty one there wow the
split was ridiculous on that one
at the plate
and i know that's one of the things he's
working on as he punches out stassi
right there
on a good firm fastball
the fastball he's working the bottom of
the strike zone he's utilizing all of
his pitches a little bit more he's got
six strikeouts good bunt laid down by
mayfield scuba off balance in the ground
and they got him good scoop by nunez
athletic play
by tarik skubal renato nunez leads
things off in the home fifth two nothing
angels
and is a strikeout victim here splitter
got him
this casket drives one deep right field
that ball's belted that ball's gone
tigers are on the board oh baby castro
goes up with the right approach we
talked about ambushing shohei ohtani on
that first pitch he's been throwing that
get me over breaking ball and there's no
question in my mind castro sitting on
that pitch and boy he hit a absolute
bomb to right field 1-2 pitch got him
swinging made him chase that slider and
that's five strikeouts for rotani
tonight one gone for jonathan scope who
has struck out and popped out tonight a
wild swinging miss by scope
six strikeouts for otaki
[Applause]
[Music]
the o2
swung on and missed got him to chase
that one and a splitter gets him
swinging struck him out to the seventh
we go tarek skubal continues to deal
right back to him
stop it
he was ready dom goes iglesias and with
one away the angels have back-to-back
singles here's max stassi
on the ground in the hole nice play by
castro long throw and he gets statsy
what a play by harold castro
owning that position deep in the hole
popped up and threw a bullet to first
that's going to be it for terrex school
cisnero to try and get the final out of
the seventh the one-two
got him cisnero proves he's the man for
the job bottom of the seventh the
mind-blowing number there is 64 pitch
incredible here's harold castro
and castro bounces it to fletcher
two gone 2-2
to left
for upton to retire the side devin
strong from ohtani hey otani will lead
things off in the eighth
oh tony got it he got it number 40.
a franchise record for left-handed
hitters
one halos
oh uncle
joe hey otani number 40.
seven incredible innings on the mound
and he just smashes the baseball a mile
hey is there ever a drop to mike moment
in baseball that might be it right there
with that swing
it's been the shohe otani show in
detroit tonight
oh instead just a 98 mile an hour
aspirin tablet this brush is a fastball
with some movement at 98.
90 pitches will get him through eight
wow that gives him 100 innings pitch
this year he'll iglesias well the
glaciers got a fastball he gets up to 98
miles per hour
[Applause]
fly ball
right field it's deep back goes adele
he's got it on the track lacie is one
out away from wrapping up shohei
ohtani's eighth win of the year
i'm not sure they're going to feel the
same about ohtani tonight because he
absolutely dominated the home squad
iglesias saves his 27th the angels win
the first two of the series
you